vous savez
il ya un autre sujet cette émission le
sujet c'est l'amour et daniel mot à
ces partis à marrakech également vers
les bois
elle est partie à marrakech
daniel cherche à voir le loup depuis 58
ans
on l'attend l'instant elle n'entend même
pas vu le loup le renard et la belette
et malheureusement pour le moment elle
n'a vu ni le loup
ni sac
[Rires]
le bureau est sorti en club
oui et à partager son trajet avec un
charmant au chauffeur nommé air ed a
créé da
avec lequel elle aurait eu un crush seul
témoin guillaume genton rythme que c'est
le chauffeur d guillaume genton oui
guillaume genton un chauffeur c'est le
seul chroniqueur dans le paf sous le
manteau
je rappelle bien sûr que la brigade
financière à la hausse
qui s'est passé
je voudrais d'ailleurs vous interroger
la mienne je peux refaire la
reconstitution des faits nous sommes
donc samedi soir daniel s'installe dans
une voiture de luxe elle est habillée
d'une robe à l'été magnifique est belle
elle avait mis une magnifique robe ouais
je sais qu'on peut rappeler les raisons
de leur cabane
non sauf moi par mes rations on est
vraiment sur l'amour assume et n'hésitez
pas à faire des bisous hervé web on fera
des bisous avant lui faut encore des
bisous et bien on le rend leur faire
entendre on parle on parlera des raisons
demain d'accord pour l'instant
j'aurais qu'on a sur l'amour ce qui me
reste capillon fourré gestapo
chams année histoire daniel st star dans
une voiture de luxe pour une femme et de
luxe nous étions de barbie la voiture de
la rose c'est vrai que en tant que
barbie vous avez envie de kent
elle taille au bout de quelques minutes
la tension monte
oui elle avait 18 sept ont appelé un
médecin qui
la chaleur s'installe
et reda vous surnomme très vite magath
et
non être carrément obama gâteuse
[Rires]
n'est pas ce que je vais demander ben
c'est un petit peu ma gâteuse magali
magail les allusions coquines
s'enchaînent voilà entre les deux
protagonistes
on parle même d'une métaphore sur le
croque-monsieur notre ange non non c'est
vrai il ya eu des si vous aviez sur le
croque monsieur non mais y avait plein
de trucs en longueur des pains au lait
des croque-monsieur fin et c'était
mais je pense que il est bien pris en
main n'est pas de faire des gros sous
entendu il faisait oui tu sais qu'il ya
pas que la voiture qui est loin de faire
le plein
c'est du sans plomb
j'adore marrakech est ce que ça
t'intéresse de visiter mon souci
[Applaudissements]
je peux le dire quoi il ya quelque chose
d'assez choquant aller vite parce que
reda c'est quelqu'un de très romantique
et il lui a dit mais pour toi daniel je
serai prêt à arrêter mon travail pendant
un an faire le tour du monde avec toi
elle a eu si tu peux juste le bouillet
en dix minutes avec
sa mâchoire proposé à lui apporter
l'hôtel formule 1 l'hôtel formule 1 et
le toril
c'est vrai parce qu'on passait devant
donc cbc survie des dons bien dit quoi
mais j'ai dit qu'on pouvait faire une
petite pause que ça son ensemble son
pot d'échappement fumer un peu échauffés
donc
[Applaudissements]
hier s'arrête à la station service mais
ils m'ont à sandwich triangle j'ai envie
d'être ta petite niche tôt
c'est vrai alors c'est vrai fan yen à
l'attention de daniel vous la voyez
comme ça
daniele righi
et pris en sandwich triangle rond
l'approché daniel ceduna croque monsieur
ça chauffe très très vite à bat daniela
balafon rigole abbaoui non mais si oui à
nos jeunes méritent une balle est une
barrière à lille est électrifiée et bien
j'ai une bonne et une surprise mais non
reda et là ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'ailleurs on est pas dans la merde
monde
c'est à la
bcc un manteau un ami ouais puisque son
frère même travaillé que moi
tarik à l'appel repeat mon frérot tariq
qui est aussi dans les parages là on a
toute la famille eugénie ya tarik la
reda il ya moi
reda
[Rires]
tu sais si j'avais été toi samedi soir
j'aurais été au casino car à voir autant
de chance
ça n'arrive pas tous les quatre matins
le gros lot est là
j'aurais gagné 1 motus j'en ai gratté un
jeu peut-être même à morpion
reda aujourd'hui tu es
comme on le dit entre nous
l'élu
ou l'élue
france avec un grand l
ena tu le sais on ne font pas bien tu as
fait ce trajet avec des allemands mais
ce trajet ça n'était pas seulement les
kilomètres 1 qui s'amassaient c'était
aussi
l'amour image et de vie de l'amour qui
tapait au coeur de daniel
le choeur de daniel
jeu qui a bien sûr connu des émotions
incroyables depuis maintenant cinquante
huit on
a connu des émotions
il reste 2
et reda aujourd'hui
tuer l'élue
daniel janin joueur
a envie de forniquer avec toi
[Applaudissements]
il ya daniel moreau qui me dit du
romantisme à 19h23 les méchants
est-ce qu'on peut les faire danser non
alors par la star 2008 est pour
l'instant mais j'aimerais savoir juste
daniel est ce que tu es toujours attiré
par reda attendait il est encore plus
beau de buka c'est parce que le début
et encore elle n'a pas dû allonger
ya encore plus beau a allongé en
tranches de tonka
et des frites à côté de la salle avant
je suis assez content les poissons vous
êtes
allongé comme ça
c'est l'émotion civile reda reste quand
même trop
reda sache le ouais en amour il n'y a
pas de geste barrier
est aujourd'hui l'amour et a frappé à
ton levier de vitesse
j'espère que tu n'es pas en automatique
qu'il est est ce que tu vas devoir
passer la cinquième il ya quand même
pris mon genou pour son frein à main
pendant tout le voyage
pas mal qu'il ya eu j'ai vu le petit
manège
c'est pas bien ça c'est pas à toi
lanières
est ce que vous avez envie de passer une
soirée avec reda à mes frais bien
entendu à tout ça j'aimerais voir ce
qu'il ya sous le capot quoi
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est vrai que vous avez envie de vous
soulevez son capot ya une petite manette
ici
je suis
comme ça les a pas
regardés ses yeux résumé alors dites moi
j'ai les yeux qui pétillent pire
non là je crois qu'il est grippé
personne est grippé j'espère que sa tête
est grippé mais son corps
daniel est ce que tu as quelque chose à
lui dire ce soir et soit h la nuit voilà
si tu as envie de mercy la nuit avec lui
ce soir ferait atelier dira oui ou non
on n'est pas là pour enfiler des perles
moi j'ai l'impression qu'on était sur
l'autoroute du bonheur maintenant où
va-t-on s'arrêter je ne
toucherai bouffe la lame à toi
alors mais bon on l'entend on l'entend
peu jeune homme donc oui les jeunes
alors
reda
c'est aussi je sais que toi aussi tu as
eu ce qu'on appelle un flash cimento en
espagnol el pais
médard est ce que tu veux réservé sa
réponse pour demain et revenir
réfléchir je me laisse sans que ses
débuts il
va et charles esthéticienne demain matin
il sera prêt pour le grand saut de
m'asseoir je préfère attendre demain
voilà est réservé sa réponse demain
j'aimerais fléchi donc d'accord vous
pouvez attendre jusqu'à demain au cddp
une urgence
[Rires]
je viens
une journée près on va voilà on avait
rêvé ce soir là les rêver soir
exactement salon et puisqu'il demande la
réflexion c'est que c'est pas non mais
oui et c'est que c'est pas oui ça à la
légère une réflexion une réflexion
j'avais quelque chose à dire avant
de
passer un bon moment ouais c'est bon
mais c'est vrai gentleman il a mis ma
chanson très pas préféré dans la voie de
référé eh bien c'était un peu de
tristesse et une plaie surnombre donc
mais ça prouve que cet âge intrigue et
oui le surnom de l'ami si je veux dire
[Rires]
la mise alors
[Applaudissements]